from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Mr Beast Burger in the UK and
the US this is food Wars
a Mr Beast dial Burger comes in double
and triple the B Star Burger in the UK
also comes in two sizes the double and a
triple it's a dripping grease holy shh
you see how wet this is let's weigh a
triple Burger now to see whose Burger is
bigger look how gross these scales are
by the way the b-style triple in the UK
weighs 270 grams the US triple B style
burger weighs 290 grams
in the U.S Mr Beast Burger has one size
of crinkle cut fries they come in either
unseasoned or seasoned in the UK we also
just have one size of fries and they
come as either seasoned
or as unseasoned speaking of fries the
menu offers a Chris style burger who's
Chris his Burger has fries on it and for
this they charge you an extra dollar or
in the UK an extra British pound this
got me wondering how many fries come on
this burger and does that warrant an
extra dollar charge let's count and find
out
one two three
that seems reasonably generous 27 fries
on my Cristal Burger but what about the
cost of the fries let's count how many
fries coming in order one two three
can't do that one 92. let's go by volume
for an extra dollar you get 33 grams of
fries an order of fries total is 133
grams how do we figure that out you're
paying four Pence three per chip we had
33 grams equal a dollars
how much was it one pound 17 worth of
chips in the burger I think technically
you're paying like an extra pound for
this one compared to the Beast Burger
so you actually are you are getting
slightly more than you pay for
size 17p
it looks like
Al Berger per gram each fry costs three
cents but if you get the crinkle cut
fries on the side each fry per gram
costs 4 cents so you're actually getting
a better deal on fries if you get them
in the crisp Burger than separately
that's pretty nice that took way longer
than it should have and I'm sorry
here is everything you'll find at a Mr
Beast Burger in the UK here's everything
you can find in the US at a Mr Beast
Burger there's a slight problem with our
usual exclusives approach to this
section which is namely that the UK
doesn't have any everything on the menu
here is also available in the US however
I do have a suspicion that some of these
things might be slightly different so
we're going to take a look the only food
exclusive the US has over the UK is in
the US you can get a Mr Beast impossible
Burger made with the impossible beef
that's because at the time of recording
this impossible beef is not available in
the UK that's because it contains a key
ingredient called soy lehemoglobin AKA
heme according to Impossible Foods it's
what makes some Meats taste so meaty and
creates the bleeding effect PM is
classified as Gras generally recognized
as safe in the US however it does not
have regulatory approval in the UK or
the EU just yet although impossible
foods do say they're working on it
besides that the only drink again in the
US can't get in the UK is Sierra Mist UK
consider yourself lucky Sierra Miss
sucks
start down the same with the classic so
we have the Mr Beast style double two
smash patties there's cheese and then
there's also pickles chopped onions some
mustard and some ketchup I love Smash
Burgers and I wish more places did Smash
Burgers you end up with these incredibly
like crispy bits on the outside you see
this
that's just like pure flavor
it's like beef candy it's brilliant
it's really good
that's pretty good I do like this I
don't know if I would consider this a
smash Patty though tasty juicy then of
course we have the b style triple which
has the same toppings but an extra beef
patty a Chris style what up Chris
whoever you are fries and bacon on the
sandwich
yesterday's just okay so this is the UK
Chris style burger we have bun we have
fries with some cheese two beef patties
and on the bottom just one piece of
bacon and it's kind of that like cheap
bacon I associate this with uh buffets
particularly when you go to an
all-inclusive resort in Central Europe
I have to try this one it looks so good
they didn't skimp on the fries this
thing is dense so this is the Carl's
Deluxe in the UK what they've done is
for some reason only flipped one of the
burger buns and then they've kind of
used that to create a grilled cheese
effect which in the UK we call a cheese
toasty but then within that you have a
beef patty with cheese on both sides
as well as some grilled onions the
Chandler style there's nothing on this
just burgers and cheese like whose food
is made for like 10 year olds Chandler
come on man what's going on this is a
very very basic cheeseburger it's just
bun cheese meat
cheese meat
bun it just feels a little bit like when
you're a little kid and all you want is
a hamburger with bread and beef
it's too dry come on Chanda live a
little man get some sauce involved maybe
even some pickles who knows I don't know
what the Nashville tastes like over
there in the UK sticking Tenders in here
but this one
crunchy and of course they also have the
option of just like a regular chicken
sandwich
and weird way it kind of reminds me of
the McChicken but like not as flavored
any fast food place this would be like
the dollar menu chicken sandwich this is
nine dollars bro
no no no no
this is the Nashville
this is so offensive to the people of
Nashville
people of Nashville Look Away now
because the UK is about to start another
Revolutionary War so the problem is uh
in the UK no one really knows what
Nashville hot chicken is supposed to
look like so fast food chains can get
away with serving things like this and
people don't know enough to call them
out on it what is this come on what
they've done as far as I can tell is
just take standard chicken tenders and
then I think they've added maybe some of
the seasoning from the seasoned fries
and then tried to pass that off as a hot
chicken sandwich
I'm not good with spice there's nothing
going on there zero scoville's that's
not Nashville nor is it hot you can also
just get a chicken tender sandwich I
don't understand what the difference is
particularly this one has pickles on it
I just wish we could up our chicken game
in the UK at the moment we're not doing
the best job of it and unfortunately Mr
Beast Burger is not our hero when it
comes to that so Carl making a second
appearance on the menu apparently as a
grilled cheese that is two tap buns
flipped over but she's smashed in the
middle of it the six bucks oh that's
that's really funny how much is a loaf
of bread and a bunch of slices of
American cheese you can make like 20 of
these this thing looks sad I think both
of the buns are supposed to be flipped
interesting aesthetic
cheese hasn't really melted properly so
it's not stuck to this so it's just a
very smooth shiny layer of cheese is
your seasoned fries
no
it does give me like a slight Nando's
vibe to it in terms of the heat level
and some of the flavor profiles as well
like almost like a Peri-Peri seasoning
on this Mr Beast burger also offers
something called b style fries which
comes loaded with caramelized onions
American cheese pickles Mayo ketchup and
mustard this is it right here I don't
know about this guys maybe not the most
visually appealing however I like the
idea of fries and pickles together
cheers
I really like these these are really
good and one dessert
a chocolate chip cookie
it's a pretty good cookie that's not bad
this is like pretty stale obviously
we're a bit lacking and exclusives in
the UK but maybe I can take some
pre-existing menu items and combine them
to create a Harry style burger
trademark Harry Style the Chandler style
which was the very plain one I'm going
to take some of the fake Nashville Hot
Chicken which is not very hot at all
lamb that straight on top actually I
think this will benefit from some of the
moisture on this bun so I'm going to
keep that as well so we're going for Mr
Beast style fries because I quite liked
the crisp Style with the fries on it
here goes the Harry Styles
[Music]
you know what we might have done
something though I actually don't mind
the combination of chicken and beef I
think that kind of works oh god what
have I done they were too preoccupied
with whether or not they could they
didn't stop to think about whether or
not they should but honestly don't hate
it give it a try so from my signature
Burger here's what I'm gonna do I think
this is a really good idea I'm excited
about this I'm gonna take a Carl's
grilled cheese and a second Carl's
grilled cheese
and mine's gonna be the b-style burger
but instead of buns it's two grilled
cheeses check this out grilled cheese
double patties should I put fries on it
too why not we'll make it a crisp style
because these fries have all the
seasoning and stuff on it they have all
the ketchup and of all the sauces and
everything on it one has caramelized
onions too okay there they got the Beast
burger or the Beast style burger this is
the Joe style burger we can also call
this I've been told they look like old
Mr Beast so this could be old Mr B style
burger or Mr Beast with no serotonin
burger or I kind of look like that guy
from Game of Thrones Burger so whatever
you want to call it but here we go oh
man this I'm like excited about this
look how good this looks
I'm an absolute genius this is so good
oh man
Jimmy put this on the menu
put this on the menu one more
like I think I really want to keep
eating this that one more bite I'm sorry
[Music]
here's a USB style double burger combo
over here it will run you
15.29 that same combo in the UK is 14
pounds 99. 15 quid for that yes
holy we own something none of it but
what about the delivery fees using the
Mr Beast Burger site in the U.S the same
combo with tax delivery fees and tip
costs
28.72 increasing the cost by 87.8
percent oof so if possible you may want
to go pick up your food it's a similar
deal here in the UK we checked this
order on deliveroo and they charge a two
pounds 49 delivery fee and a two pounds
and five pence service charge which
jacks the price up by almost a third one
big difference worth pointing out is the
Tipping culture in the UK and the US
it's much less common to tip in the UK
than it is in America in the UK If you
go to a restaurant for some food it's
usually common to give maybe a 10 or a
12.5 service charge if the service has
been good but you can't even opt out of
that if you don't want to pay it
particularly where delivery is concerned
I think tipping is even less common in
the UK I Got a notification actually on
my delivery app the other day to say
that six percent of people in my area
have been tipping their drivers recently
so that's six out of every 100 people
are tipping a delivery driver when I say
that we don't have as much of a tipping
culture in the UK it's not that we
really stingy we just generally have a
much higher minimum wage in the UK than
you do in the US so there's less
Reliance on tips to make ends meet for
service industry stuff
we thought we'd take a look back over
the story of Mr Beast Burger to give you
all some context it all started with a
YouTube video back in 2020 in which Mr
Beast opened a single drive-through
restaurant where the food is free and
customers would even get free money for
visiting obviously thousands of people
showed up in the video got over a
hundred million views at the end of the
video Mr Beast announced Mr Beast Burger
his chain of burgers which was available
across the U.S for delivery he partnered
with virtual dining Concepts a platform
which matches brands with existing
restaurants and kitchens to prepare and
deliver food by using existing kitchens
Mr beastberg was able to expand rapidly
opening 300 locations in the US in the
first week followed by more in the UK
and Canada shortly after for context it
took McDonald six years to open 300 Us
locations you can start to see why
Brands love virtual kitchens at the time
of filming this there is only one brick
and mortar Mr Beast Burger location
recently opened in New Jersey's American
Dream mall at the Grand Opening over a
hundred thousand fans showed up some
waiting in line all night it was a
massive success captured by Colin Samir
who documented the entire day according
to the dock at the Grand Opening Mr
Beast Burger sold 6 212 burgers and
broke the world record by three times
Guinness world records has asked for
proof and at the time of this recording
has not made it official but it has an
opening sunshine and Roses pretty much
anybody can apply to become a virtual
kitchen for Mr Beast Burger there's a
form on the virtual dining concert's
website where you can tell them which
facilities you have in the kitchen so if
you have a fryer a flat top and a fridge
and you normally make fried food even if
you just have a single location
you can cook Mr Beast Burger that's all
it takes a fryer a flat top and a fridge
I mean you can buy a deep fryer for
pretty cheap and I feel like you could
install a flat top on like pretty much
any kitchen and everyone's got a fridge
so I feel like I could probably cook Mr
Beast burger if I wanted to a wide
variety of restaurants acting as virtual
kitchens has led to a slew of quality
control issues for the chain the food is
coming from all types of restaurants
independent of each other so what you're
getting may be a bit of a crap shoot so
we went ahead and got Mr Beast burger
from a second location first the
Chandler style and that's a say it looks
pretty good right very impressed the
Chandler style from restaurant
number two
okay the first thing I noticed is the
Burger's not wrapped
is that okay it's bigger but I mean that
clearly different bun this is more of a
smash Patty how it's like really like
almost like paper thin where this just
looks like tiny burgers Chandler burger
right
the cheese makes this one
[Music]
no it's like a different quality of meat
too
I think that this actually is pertinent
information this is from a restaurant in
Glendale this was from the Buca Di
beppos at Universal Studios
hot chicken sandwich all right again
place number one the place we like
saying it's Nashville but instead of
doing chicken sandwiches and doing
chicken tender sandwiches bit of a
disparity between a and b
m
that's spicy that's disappointing
there's no spice to that I mean this one
yeah
um
that however is much better despite some
of these quality discrepancies Mr Beast
Burger shows no sign of slowing down its
growth earlier this year Mr Beast
tweeted that the brand has already
shared over a hundred million dollars of
Revenue with restaurants Across America
when he says shared it means that not
all the money is going to Mr Beast nor
is all the money going to the
restaurants the restaurants will
obviously take a large cup but then some
of the money will go to Virtual dining
Concepts and I'm sure some of it is
going to Mr Beast as well for example
one restaurant in Dallas Texas claimed
it sold seven thousand dollars worth of
Mr Beast burgers in a single day Mr
Beast actually once described the launch
of Mr East Burger as a gamble but so far
it's looking like that gamble paid off
we actually collected today's order in
store and I had to kind of place the
order there by showing the guy my phone
and he kind of tapped it all through for
me he was actually kind of surprised at
how much the burgers cost he said they
looked quite expensive I guess it just
means that he wasn't aware of how many
fees are being added on so that either
the delivery platform or virtual dining
Concepts can get a fair cut of the
profit
it seems like the nutritional stats for
Mr Beast Burger are actually the same in
the U.S and the UK a b style with double
patties is 950 calories 66 grams of fat
23 grams of saturated fat 43 grams of
carbs 41 grams of protein and 1 840
milligrams of sodium note that is 80 of
your daily sodium make it a b-style
triple and the calories go up to 1160
which is over half of your daily
allowance what you really have to look
out for here is the saturated fat a
b-style triple contains 150 percent of
your daily recommended intake bump it up
to a beast style double burger combo
with unseasoned fries and a can of
Sierra Mist gives you a grand total of 1
330 calories pop it up to a triple
and you hit
1540 calories
comparing the b style burger to other
fast food chain Burgers Mr Beast calorie
wise lands about here
it's pretty high up there but good news
for Jimmy no one in America cares
realize
Realize Real fries